hi there this is steve kaufman
um i want to talk today about the uh
earthquake in japan the tsunami the loss
of life the situation there
because quite honestly i just can't stop
thinking about it
um
i
lived in japan for nine years
first arrived there in uh january of
1971.
uh i have had dealings with japan for 40
years
my youngest son was born there
i lived there with my family
i've worked there
and i it's just been a big part of my
life i have
i have the greatest amount of respect
for
uh
japanese culture japan
and it i just can't imagine what it is
like
to be there
especially up in the northeast
where we're now hearing of ten thousand
possible
uh people who will have lost their lives
um
there's always unsettling
uh
development around their nuclear
facilities up there
there's talk about another aftershock of
a magnitude of seven
there's a shortage of of goods in stores
even in tokyo
obviously people are in a state of shock
there are millions of people without
heat and electricity
in the northeast which is a cold part of
japan
i cannot imagine
what it is like
and i visited kobe after the
earthquake in 1996
and it just seems like japan gets
slammed hit with these natural disasters
with with uh appalling
regularity
so all i wanted to say was that i know
as a canadian who has lived in japan who
has worked with japanese people in the
lumber business primarily and i know
many canadians who have worked with
japan
that
just about everyone has the
fondest possible feelings for
japanese people the greatest respect for
japanese people a great sense of
of
gratitude to have had the opportunity to
work with japanese people
over these many years
and you know i was thinking about the
qualities of the japanese that i find so
admirable and i came up with this this
one word that keeps on
coming back to me which is respect
r-e-s-p-e-c-t
and if you break it down
using the first letters of a number of
qualities that all come around this
whole respect word
japanese people have respect for each
other more than most countries where i
have lived or visited or worked everyone
is respected even uh someone who is a
has a relatively menial job is respected
people operate in an atmosphere of
respect and trust and we're seeing this
i think in the way people are responding
to the uh to the uh disaster
uh up uh in in the northeast
uh the second thing about japan is that
it's a relatively equal country it's
probably the most egalitarian country
in the world
there's no tremendous differences
between rich and poor people don't
flaunt their wealth
um
so it goes hand in hand with this
respect it's respect even though people
talk about japan as this vertical
society where you know the
the underlings have to bow
to the bosses and so forth in fact it's
not quite like that and it's it's very
much of an egalitarian society where
people where people respect each other
s so we got r-e-s s is for self-reliance
the japanese are not the kind of people
who expect someone else to do things for
them they don't have this
developed sense of entitlement that i
think we have here in north america they
know that they have to do things for
themselves and they're willing to do it
they're willing to buckle down and do
what they have to do which again we're
seeing in the reaction of ordinary
people
to to the the circumstances up in the
northeast
resp perseverance the japanese they stay
with it they don't they don't promise
you oh yeah no problem i can do that
after this and then not deliver they
deliver they stay with it until the job
is done
and and i think this is why they've been
successful in so many things they
persevere they stay with it and they're
not easily discouraged by adversity as
we're going to see as japan rebuilds
from this latest
tragedy
the next thing about the japanese
another e here r-e-s-p-e energy they're
very dynamic energetic people they're
energetic in their work and they're
energetic in play and especially this
younger generation of japanese who are
often the butt of criticism if i compare
them to when i was in japan in the 70s
they love to have a good time they're
great people to be with
full of energy
always looking for some new venture
something they can get into so they're
energetic people and they're going to
need that energy to rebuild
respect
r-e-s-p-e-c curiosity the japanese are
curious they're not afraid to learn they
go on trips overseas to study you'll
find japanese people studying flamenco
music in spain
or
you know buddhist
uh
you know philosophy in thailand or or
whatever or learning about new
technology or learning about their own
history
they're curious about the history of the
world they're they're very curious
they're interested in learning about
things
curious and finally the japanese are
thorough
they are thorough they are
people who pursue perfection now
pursuing perfection you're not likely to
achieve perfection but it's a large part
of why they are so creative and they are
a very creative people they have a very
unique culture and in recent years the
number of patents coming out of japan is
tremendous their influence on
on modern pop culture on
architecture on food on so many aspects
of our culture is is very very
significant so they are unique and
creative
uh culture and a lot of that culture
comes in my opinion comes from this
commitment to thoroughness they are not
a superficial people so
i am convinced that for all of these
reasons
the reasons that i respect in the
japanese that they will overcome all
these difficulties
and uh i'm sure they'll be criticizing
criticism flying around the government
should have done this tokyo electric
power company should have done that but
relative to what would have been the
situation in just about any other
country i can think of i think the
japanese will recover more quickly
and will start once again to build and
create
uh a dynamic society and culture and
economy so i really uh want to offer my
deepest sympathies uh to people in japan
and you know my
sense of you know gokuro
and i'm looking forward to my next trip
to japan thank you for listening